à l'intersaison quatre joueurs
américains ont débarqué aux cougars si
leur intégration n'a pris que quelques
minutes les entraînements collectifs ont
été très perturbée cet hiver à cause des
intempéries les repères ne sont donc pas
encore là pour le fun in dès la reprise
du championnat non il n'y a pas de
pression mais c'est vrai qu'on n'est
peut-être pas forcément préparé comme il
faut avec le mauvais temps on a eu un
peu de mal à jouer des matchs sur mars
sur mars est un peu fin février donc
c'est pas forcément évident on n'a
jamais eu l'équipe au complet depuis le
depuis le début donc là c'est le premier
match on joue tous ensemble sur ce
premier match les cougars font la course
en tête dès les premières balles sans
vraiment creuser l'écart sur la dernière
manche les expos des remous passe devant
sur deux erreurs défensives mini
monteyne défaite 6-5 mais j'irai malgré
la défaite cet arbre macho revenir à la
fin ils ont profité d'une petite erreur
mais moi
paradoxalement je veux dire je suis
assez content du niveau de jeu de
l'équipe pour ce premier match de saison
arnaud faux peut également être
satisfait des recrues qui assument leur
statut lanceur américain wesley moore
débute le deuxième match sur le
monticule le temps de neuf manches eelv
a martyrisé la tacc valdoisienne auteur
notamment de neuf strike deux buts sur
balles de tom mahieu et mathieu dufour
feront le reste score final 11 8 herman
et montigny partagent logiquement les
points sur les deux matches mais pour
retrouver l'élite les cougars devront
être plus rigoureux défensivement